um
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on we would everything
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male dog
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is a beta girl
david patman
he is a baby
david patman
he is a baby
david patman
he is a baby
david pacman
he is a beta
david patman
he is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming out i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
actually like because you're asking
bizarre questions
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
back down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you
and never talk to the new world
[Music]
that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
scratching
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpsters
[Music]
[Music]
well it's great to be back with
everybody we have a trump rally tonight
and it actually might remain slightly on
message in the sense that this rally
doesn't seem exclusively masturbatory
for trump's ego
he actually has now endorsed a vile
disgusting person named jd vance who's
running for ohio senate
vance already spoke at the rally this is
all about
supporting vance and other candidates
and
jd vance is a guy you know i'll admit
jd vance
wrote this book hillbilly elegy some
years ago and i read it a couple years
ago and in reading it he seemed kind of
reasonable where i was like wow okay
this is a republican like we don't agree
on tax policy fine
but
he explains the cultural
path towards conservatism and he doesn't
seem like a bomb thrower and he doesn't
seem like a trump guy and early j.d
vance wasn't a trump guy
and all of a sudden before you know it
the guy is as vile a trump guy as
anybody else trump's endorsing him and i
feel absolutely horrible that i ever
thought jd vance might be an even
remotely reasonable guy so part of this
rally this is in delaware ohio not the
state of delaware but the it
the rally is actually a state of
delusion but it's in the state of ohio
from a geographical standpoint if people
understand
what i'm saying okay so let's just put
it there and uh and and leave it at that
the uh rally it sort of has already
started
but trump is scheduled to speak just
about 45 minutes from now so we're going
to track all of that
and um it's
it is what it is you know we will we'll
have to see what goes on
um
i have so many different things to go
over with everybody let's just get right
into it
first of all
wait what is this i don't even know what
this is oh no that's nothing oh okay no
no no oh i see what's going on so
yesterday we had the marjorie taylor
green under oath hearings they were a
complete and total joke i mean it was
completely farcical she all of a sudden
didn't remember anything until her
lawyer started asking questions and she
was like oh yeah at 107 pm they moved us
into a secret undisclosed location i'm
not at liberty to say at 1 12 p.m i
received a call from my chief of staff
and then we put together a tweet which i
retweeted and then lauren
hey um
have you ever said nancy pelosi should
be shot i don't remember i don't you
don't deny it
i i just don't remember that's basically
how the eight hours went yesterday but
here's one particularly interesting
moment where
the judge just rolls his eyes
at the idea
that people need handguns to prevent
government tyranny this was a moment in
the questioning this was the
petitioner's lawyer from the
organization free speech for people
and marjorie taylor green says yeah you
might need guns in order to you know
protect yourself from a tyrannical
government and just watch the judge who
rolls his eyes this is maybe the the
most emblematic moment of the entire the
entire thing
and in that statement
what you say is if you can defend
yourself you can stop a tyrannical
government you guys see you guys see the
judge roll his eyes there i just love
that the the this is it's i'm not i
don't know what the judge is thinking
overall i don't know what the judge is
going to rule it's just it was a funny
moment okay one once more um
and in that statement
what you say is if you can defend
yourself you can stop a tyrannical
government
however
i don't know why that really got me i i
that that one moment is great okay i
don't know anything else about the judge
and uh we one thing that was actually
notable is the judge didn't talk at all
about food the entire trial
hearing which we if you watch the
written house trial you would have been
surprised by by the way how are the
calzones the food is here let's take a
break lunch is here uncharged piccolo's
pizza is here but we have subway
tomorrow warm food around noon exactly
so that was uh definitely a culture
shock for lack of a better term
peter says via super chat he will not
advance trump never donates his money
fending for himself mike haiku for you
david pakman show beautiful haiku
denver says how do you know trump will
be dangerous and unhinged tonight maybe
he'll be perfectly measured and
reasonable i'm looking forward to his
mango price analysis thanks for the
stream yeah this has become a joke so on
youtube actually maybe on twitch and
facebook as well i actually don't know
but on youtube we're calling today's
stream donald trump 2022 rally in ohio
dangerous and unhinged it's almost a
joke at this point every once in a while
someone will write to me or they'll
actually pay for a super chat which i
think is what denver is alluding to and
they'll say
david it's not really journalism to call
the rally dangerous and unhinged before
it starts
you really shouldn't do that you know
because it's not exactly journalism
i'm not a journalist i'm just a
commentator and at this point it's a
joke upon you it's like a three-layer
joke but we've covered 150 trump rallies
and they've all been dangerous and
unhinged can can you guys please give me
the leeway to expect today's to be
dangerous and unhinged until we know
otherwise is that
fair can we just say that that's what
it it's not exactly journalism to obtain
because they don't
okay guys all right please we're just
having a good time here
mike pillow just announced his own
social media platform
franksocial.com is that right
franksocial.com oh my god yeah
i should make an account
is this a is this a parody it looks like
a satirical website look at this
frank social the voice of free speech
also if he's mike lindell why is
everything frank
it's kind of weird
anyway we'll deal with that a little bit
later uh okay so in any case we're
standing by for um for for donald trump
here
let's see i want to say thank you to
adam gingrich adam gingrich just gifted
a
membership on my website and when you
gift them
many of you know that gifts in general
there's a gifter and a giftee
because adam has gifted a membership
tamara becker now gets a membership we
are now at 715
well now 714 people who have requested
memberships which is crazy it's an
absolutely insane number and i very much
appreciate that okay so we did marjorie
taylor green
let's do oh
do how many of you remember
that at the start of the invasion of
ukraine by russia i said this is
speculative but i believe
putin may be ill very very ill
and that either that is clouding his
judgment about this war or he wants to
go out in some kind of final blaze of
some kind of
suicidal mania anyway now everybody's
talking about it really does seem like
putin is sick
this is this is relatively new video of
him he looks pale and bloated he is
gripping the table like his life depends
on it seemingly for stability
he seems almost sunken into the chair
uh
almost like he doesn't have the energy
to lift his he's almost like i don't
know how to describe it but 99 of the
meeting he's just pressed up against the
chair it's very strange okay it's very
very strange now here's a question david
do you support russia's invasion of
ukraine
do i even need to answer that guys
this may be a new viewer but is that
i feel like it's offensive to even
answer that question
no i don't support the invasion no i
don't it's a bad invasion i'm against it
um so anyway it does look like
everything's kind of falling off the
walls for vlad
and um we're gonna keep we're gonna keep
an eye on it we're gonna keep an eye on
it i want to say a few thank yous beth
graham the bearded atheist the freak and
gw jumpman have re-upped twitch prime
subscriptions very much appreciate that
guys
uh okay we already did that one why
isn't mike pillow's social media app
called pillow talk that makes much more
sense than frank social doesn't it
hey david are you pro-trump because
you're televising his speech
great question let's see if we can
figure it out in what's left of this uh
and what's left of this stream oh a
couple other things here's a couple
interesting things trump
tried this is very interesting this
shows you how trump has lost control of
the monster he created
trump wanted to brag about the vaccine
at a speech in florida a couple days ago
and he had to sort of
equivocate because he knows his audience
hates the vaccine check this out our
greatest achievements was
getting the vaccine done in nine months
and achievements instead of five and a
half to twelve years but
the problem is you know we saved tens of
millions of lives all over the world but
i can't talk about it because our base
our beautiful base of which some of you
are there you get angry when we mention
the word vaccine don't get angry we did
it in nine months less than nine months
right
less than nine months
and frankly a lot of people are living
today because of that so
very very muted applause
for that uh for
for that declaration also from this same
speech check out how trump thinks we're
going to unify the country this this is
like unbelievable the one that we have
the path back to american unity is not
to surrender the culture wars the path
back to national unity is to decisively
win
the culture wars he believes he will
unify the country by winning imaginary
culture wars that were created by his
party
to divide the country
they create the imaginary culture wars
to divide and then they're going to win
them in order to unite i mean
can you imagine anything more idiotic so
that's his that's his plan
to um to
to unite the country for lack of a
better term as he is using it
um okay
i want to say thank you to ash murphy
and terry schwerin who have just gifted
two more memberships on my website those
go to gabriella mammarian
and ken rimmer beautiful also big thanks
to nancy harn nancy just signed up nancy
selfishly keeping the membership for
herself how dare she
no well oh man that guy was already
banned hold on a second what did that
guy do
the guy who asked whether wait hold on
somebody whose question i answered the
guy was just banned what
moderator can you tell me what just
happened why did that guy get banned i
didn't i didn't think the question was
necessarily bad faith what did he say
i i just missed what they said and
before i knew that they were banned
i kind of love it but
we don't know okay nobody knows why they
were bent
he said he didn't feel welcome well he
could just leave he doesn't have to be
banned what a strange day
all right let's continue i have um i
have other stuff for you guys let's see
what we've got
uh oh okay ron phillipkowski and his
team are on the ground in um ohio
so let's take a look at some of these
guy at trump rally says he's been to 129
grateful dead shows but now he prefers
prompt rallies i tell all my friends
i've seen jerry garcia 129 times in
concert it's better than any grateful
dead show and it smells a lot better you
know one of the reasons i don't go to
these types of rallies or the the
presence of these fetid sani cans
and um
yeah i just have a hard time imagining
that the rally smells good i just i just
don't think so
uh here's the opening prayer at the
trump rally
they pray for the living legacy of trump
for life and and we we're grateful for
the living
legacy of president donald john trump
we thank you for his willingness to
continue to organize and to travel
across our nation delivering the message
of freedom and to remind us you and me
that we play a critical part in saving
our nation we thank you o god
for the clarity of purpose you have
given to president trump we thank you
for his god-given consistency
all right no it's it's getting a little
bit uh it's nauseating yeah i agree
super chats continue to come in i love
what you're doing happy to support your
efforts i know which your your to use
thanks to you thank you very much yeah
the line at coachella for cocktails is
larger than this crowd says joe mama
david sir if desantis runs against trump
with an anti-vaccine message and forces
trump to defend it would you agree that
would be depressingly a good strategy it
would be depressingly a good strategy
absolutely
um rudy giuliani is somewhere let's see
what is he at the rally
oh he's wearing oh my god his suit is um
the lining of his suit jacket seems to
be an american flag
that can't be in accordance with the u.s
flag code can it there's no possible way
that that's gotta be
isn't that defacing considered defacing
the flag
stitching it up and putting it inside
your clothes
it is against the flag code okay good
let's see what else we've got here's
pillow
um i guess very soon he's going to be
filing some kind of lawsuit it's not
clear what kind we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
all the other judges how would you like
to been a judge back then have been the
first one to step forward and have your
family attacked or whatever that would
they lived in fear but now since we all
know the evidence is there and
everything the judges are going to be
brave remember that donald trump
appointed over i think there's almost
500 judges look at what one just hey
guys why is this guy wearing a tan suit
isn't this a serious somber event with
with the former president it seems to me
extremely disrespectful to be wearing a
tan suit how selfish is this guy that he
wears a tan suit to such an event down
in florida was that amazing they ordered
the mail scone on the airplanes it's
beautiful you know
what did he say they put mascarpone on
the airplanes i would go for that i've
never had mascarpone on an airplane
captain 42 says via super chat david i'm
currently a sustaining member of my
local public radio would you support me
becoming a pac-man subscriber at the
expense of public radio listen guys i
know you're maybe joking maybe not
i'm going to be really upfront with you
guys i have never said to anyone
cancel memberships you have and support
me instead i have never said that what i
always say is understand
that we should support
the platforms and shows that we like so
like when i talk about the twitch prime
subscriptions and don't leave your bezos
bucks unused i always say support me or
whoever but don't leave the the bezos
box in bezos pocket okay and then
sometimes i will say you know if you
have a cable subscription you're
probably giving three bucks to fox news
just bear that in mind
and then think about
you know if you like this show and you
don't like fox and you give them three
bucks and me zero it's just something to
think about but i never go around saying
cancel this or that that that's not my
that's not my thing on that note thanks
to eat the living as well as margot
cabot for the twitch prime subscriptions
that puts us at 10 and then
huge huge huge dumps of memberships on
the website big massive dumps i want to
say thanks to sheila owen
mallory
eric sapper
patrick curran
kyoko
awaya
another one from kyoko and a third one
from kyoko that's seven gifted
memberships so now i can give away seven
the next seven people in line are ryan
dassau
bryce wright get some free membership
quinn jacobson
tessa gibson
roberto braceno
julian enam
and
joseph
chonsky geez chounsky i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly if you want a
free membership
it's davidpakman.com free membership
fill that out we have
679 people currently in line i mean
listen guys there's demand if you want
to gift a membership that's super easy
you just go to my website joinpakman.com
i recommend doing yearly and then when
you check out you use the box this is a
gift you just check it are there coupon
codes available yes right above my head
see where it says sad trump that's the
code
and if you type in sad trump
uh sixty dollars becomes uh oh what's
going on don't tell me sad trump's not
working
oh no this would be embarrassing let's
try again
sad trump
there it is oh okay i think you have to
put put in the code and then check the
gift box look at that that that's
ungodly um you can also use the code
obama
that's a little it's not quite as big of
a discount okay so anyway it's all
available whatever you want it's
available
uh and one more steve giving away a
membership that's number 18
steve's membership goes to
corey lane beautiful oh this is a good
question how many total memberships have
been given away so far as of the right
before we started 183 memberships have
been given away which is incredible it's
absolutely incredible all right let's
continue
um i'm from the uk is ohio a nice state
to visit anyone recommend something
there in particular i'm going to opt out
of answering that question
how absurd is it that the trump team
organizes a rally and hires someone to
pray about how great he is at the same
rally i know it's bizarre
it's bizarre
just wanted to say i'm someone who
considers himself moderate to
conservative uh oh and anti-trump but i
enjoy watching your show because i want
to hear opposing viewpoints and you are
fact-based the right is insane thank you
i appreciate that
and john says hello sir i'm trying to
balance watching the stream with
watching playoff basketball a lot of
compelling stuff i know i uh so the
celtics play tonight
and what what's really horrible about
living in new york is i don't get the
local celtics channels anymore but now
that we're in the playoffs every game is
televised
and i do plan to be monitoring the game
very closely in fact my earpiece today
is the game
um so i'm not even going to be listening
to the trump rally i'll be here saying
whoa whoa this is unhinged but i'll
actually be watching the game
so i hope nobody takes offense to that
that's a joke by the way i will be
watching the rally
okay
let's continue with some of our other
elements from the rally here's another
mike pillow moment
yesterday was a historical day in
history it's called an historical day
pillow please the history of america
uh we filed the first
preliminary injunction in the state of
arizona
polygamy
a junction that's a preliminary
adjunction
nuclear proliferation
to get rid of the machines once and for
all
and that's the first still wants the
machines out of here we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines many
many i want to do all 50 carrie lake and
mark fincham where the plaintiffs
and
the defendant is katie hobbs the
secretary of state and
guys i hate to tell you this but my
handheld vacuum cleaner has been listed
as a defendant
in the latest pillow suit
maricopa county and pima county county
commissioners and stuff and our
commissioners i think there
and whoever they are they're telling me
to do it um this is so important because
in this next election besides the great
candidates we're going to get we have to
have the machines gone they have to be
yeah we got to get these machines out of
here in fact just to show my support for
this lawsuit
i will destroy this machine later okay
i'm not using this i'm using this
machine
i am willing to absolutely as a sign of
solidarity we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines exactly
we'll burn this a little bit later
that'll be maybe maybe after trump
speaks okay stay tuned for that
other super chats coming in
oh i think i already read these
i did okay i already read those that's
fair
okay let's continue here's a woman at a
trump rally
trying to talk about critical race
theory and she doesn't know anything
private school private private clear
fork yeah okay so i was gonna say as a
parent what's your thoughts on what's
going on or the indoctrination of our
kids with some of their crt and some of
the other really radical things that are
it is really stressful i mean the things
that they're trying to do this woman is
so stressed that her kids were told
about history which kids these days is
just not right
you know if if it goes against god's
word then it's wrong
which god because there's like a
thousand different gods which one do you
mean here's another woman
you trying to use language to
communicate
we've talked to them earlier about
hanging flags let me ask you a question
in your neighborhood that you guys live
in your work whatever trump's flag's
still flying oh absolutely oh yes it is
wherever i mean listen a place you've
seen on tv where you live where you work
and is is trump's flag is up wherever
that is right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah see
my front yard
never went down
my porch everybody and we said if if you
want to find our house look for the
house of flags right we have 10 flags on
our porch
yes
i just did a promo for mypillow.com and
mystore.com because i said if you have
if you don't have a flag in front of
your house hang on a sec you know what
you're saying i'm unamerican right put a
flag in your front yard you have to
right can i can't even take this guy
seriously with a tan suit on you know if
he really wanted to be taken seriously
on these issues he'd be he wouldn't be
wearing a tan suit here is a guy in a
blacks for trump shirt
now here's why i love this
we've seen these folks at so many
rallies and then we try to find
information about them online and
there's like no information other than a
very strange website
and then they disappeared for the last
several rallies and here is a guy so
let's listen to a guy hey
a person that comes to your aid helps
you all the time and then when he really
wants to come to your aid
suddenly
he's a racist when he was the first one
to say that black people matter to him
he said it directly to me i'm sorry
about that
this guy's touching the interviewer a
lot
he said about ricky he's also an
extremely close talker this is a very
weird interview to me and and um
i forgot not joseph kaderson but uh
miami knights but he's done so much for
the for the black anybody know what this
guy's talking about i have no clue what
this guy's talking about
here's a guy at the trump rally says
he's mad
jimmy kimmel played my clip from the
last rally
i remember a couple weeks ago
uh this gentleman right here was
criticized for having too many hats on
his head our good friend jimmy kimmel
called you out so jimmy kimmel made fun
of me for having three hats well now i
have two hats because inflation is
getting high only can afford two hats
this rally jimmy kimmel so eventually
we'll go down to one hat but trump
rallies matter this is my 46 trump rally
we love trump i'm going to see trump
next week in nebraska i thought was is
nebraska on or is it cancelled no i
guess it is on i guess it is on um super
chat from tech strickle says hey david
tonight i'm going to keep a spreadsheet
of how many lies trump tells and the
exact quote and then your quote to
defeat it defute i've never defeated
anything but i like it
i like that
can you make a segment that if ron
desantis gets rid of disney world's
special district privileges for
opposition of his don't say gay bill
then the florida taxpayers would have to
foot the bill for desantis's pity
tyranny monday yeah i think we're going
to do that monday
oh i missed a whole bunch of twitch
people supporting thanks to crominator
hugh joppy
drak and blackblade shot x thomas narble
skies
but it's my hipaa frosty in canada
thank you very much guys that puts us at
24.
and also wow wow
i think i've got about a dozen
memberships to give away the following
people have just sent a gifted
membership
gina carroll number one jonathan
guy
number two
corey schutz number three
cheryl white number four
um
jonathan guy number five
chermaine kitchens number six stephanie
cornwell number seven
and shermaine kitchens another one
number eight okay so that's 32 the
following eight people get a free
membership i love this i love giving
these away
keegan maloney number one free
robin mace number two
mike kane number three
ivar johansen number four
steve fenwick is number five
julia walsh number six
miha lepage
number seven and stacy de guzman number
eight i love it i absolutely love it
uh also thanks to people getting
themselves memberships christopher hazy
edwards hazy is in quote so i think
that's a nickname stephanie cornwell got
herself a membership nicholas sen
and amy devin
really appreciate you guys thank you
that puts us at 36. other super chats
coming in so stressful just the media
they consume and their social circles
are stressing them out not really not
reality sad
well said
james says i'm from ohio sir absolutely
dislike all trumpists embarrassing to
say most of ohio is for trump it's
really like a 50 50 state actually it's
not it's not that overwhelmingly trump i
mean he didn't win by that much
garner says david what advice would you
give to younger people like me age 18 to
about 22 to vote for the first time how
to get us to encourage others to vote
okay so i mean listen it sounds like
you're going to vote so i don't need to
convince you to vote
but what i would tell others is listen
guys
if we don't start voting now we will
never take control of the system most
people understand that and they go well
at some point it will be our turn
if you just never enter the political
system if none of you vote it'll just be
other people that decide it'll be older
people and then it'll skip to the
younger people so you've got to get
involved you have to take control
that's what i think that that's an
effective
uh perspective
how many trump supporters do you think
believe in the big lie
i mean i can only go by what the polls
say i think at this point it's like 40
do you have any ideas why my dad left
trump after 1-6 and said sorry for not
listening to me asking him to vote biden
because of the lie
listen
you brought one person over it sounds
like although it seems like the the
heinous insurrectionist riots
had a big part to play in that
uh voicemails yeah let's let's do a
voicemail or two
um let's see
we do have a lot of voicemails starting
to rack up
um
some about the marjorie stuff some of
these are really really long
trying to find a good one for you
if we're gonna only gonna play one
voicemail i'd rather rather be good
hey david this is greg in connecticut
i love the show great humor i i just
recall when um she was asked marjorie
taylor green was asked about her being
scared during the riot
i quickly remembered a video that aoc
had posted that when they were all
together in hiding and she was offered
to wear a mask because the pandemic was
hype at the time
uh she rejected it with laughter and i
just found it funny that she said she
was scared yeah there's my few cents
have a good day man no it was just it
was d it was perjury diarrhea
uncontrollable explosive perjury the
entire the entire thing
um gamer says last year here in the uk i
voted for the first time ever in my life
i was disappointed how many people my
age 19 didn't vote it is depressing i'm
not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie
woman at trump rally explains why she
believes princess diana and jackie
onassis are still alive i want to hear
that okay first of all y'all are
so cute i love the outfits i would like
detailed explanations on every single
shirt ready set go right so
living
living and we know living
rule in the world
and you don't take down evil by being
quiet or silent right so people need to
understand who they are do they look
like them today no you think you think
princess diana is still alive absolutely
100
do you
why would she
i didn't but maybe maybe you have
something to i didn't
that you know that i don't know well you
know god speaks to us right
yeah that's enough you can figure these
things out so if people start learning
abc123 which michael jackson talked
about how many years ago right and he
sang about so when people start
understanding gematria they start
understanding the numbers
a equals one b equals two c equals three
gematria is like a hebrew numerology i
think right
gematria
i think that's hebrew numerology
it's it's pretty bonkers
he got so many people everyone has an
opinion on politics now but if you ask a
person that doesn't like trump what give
me five reasons why you don't like them
five
can't say it
they can't say it or it just is easy to
debunk they'll be like oh he's racist
misogynistic okay when okay when i mean
let's say i watch you guys on youtube
and i like you guys you guys are a great
news source
it's a news source now
all right so that's ron philipkowski's
great coverage let's now look at asin
who has some great stuff
here is speaking of jd vance speaking
earlier
who would have believed the fbi would
have got an illegal wiretap on a u.s
president okay of the past 50 years but
ladies and gentlemen the thing that
trump revealed more than any policy
achievement is that we are living in an
incredibly corrupt country
true
who would have believed that the federal
bureau of investigation our fbi would
have gotten a legal wiretap on a u.s
president who would have believed
[Applause]
it's like shut up dude
uh let's see what else okay i guess
that's it that's as far as as far as
that
all right so we're down to um just about
20 minutes until trump will speak
uh thank you to skinny latte for the
twitch prime subscription very much
appreciate that
uh guys i'm gonna say this and i'm gonna
say this with total peace and love
do not email me asking for free
memberships okay i have four emails from
people asking for free memberships do
not email me asking for free memberships
if you want a free membership just put
your name on the form it goes in order
okay i can't put your name on the form
it's davidpakman.com free membership do
if you email it just gets deleted
okay so i'm going to give away a couple
here
thanks to keith mcnicholas
kevin gouldy
and juan
peralta
i now have three more memberships to
give away
those three memberships go to catherine
logue
stephen brown
and sarah schmelzer
okay we go in order
right now
there are
675 people waiting
i can't control that
let's let's get through the list you can
gift the memberships on my website i'm
glad to give them away
uh you're on the list but you bought a
year
oh that's tough yeah i mean uh
i don't know email and asked to be taken
off the list i guess
uh super chat from matt denman could you
ever see yourself running for office
would a local election be more likely
than state or federal
um i if i ran
i it would probably be federal to be
perfectly frank i mean i'm just going to
be you know
like who the hell am i to run for
federal office i know you know i'm not
i'm not saying i'm doing it
but i don't see myself running for like
city council i think i think the issue
to be totally transparent guys is at
this point this platform is so big
and i would want to have the biggest
impact possible
for the greatest number of people
that the idea
of going from a show with an audience in
the millions
to
city council
it just it seems like i i'm giving up
too much
it doesn't make sense
so it seems to me that if i were to do
it all the conversations i people have
had with me have been for federal let me
put it that way
i'll i'll just put it that way
um
can you fax in membership requests no
next super chat david if the democrats
win the midterms what goals would you
like them to work towards that you would
personally want to see we've got to do
tax reform we re we've got to do the
climate bill uh i want to see the voting
rights bill i want to see some uh
decriminalized cannabis i mean there's
such a long list guys it's it's
you know it's pie in the sky right i
could just give you my laundry list
but there's so many things so many
different things
okay let's listen in a little bit to the
coverage we have two streams here we
have newsmax and we have right side
broadcasting they're both covering the
rally let's take a listen right off the
hook right now with notifications i
think he's on there too ad joe
follow us how appropriate is that
joe we love you joe if you're watching
we're so glad to be here uh we've got
thousands of people all in our
peripheral right now
they're in their peripheral hey in all
seriousness guys you know when i talk
about how the right is just so much more
committed to funding stuff that they
like
newsmax is crazy okay
look at the super chat situation on
newsmax
okay it is endless it is endless and
this is what i'm talking about people
are dropping hundred dollar super chats
like it's nothing
when i say that the right just says hey
if they they they like they get it
where a lot of and it's not that they
have more money it's it's not that at
all
um
it's
you know we could argue about who has
more money but they just go like we just
if if it's good we've got to fund it
that's just what it is uh it's it's wild
it's wild this is this is how they do it
how do trump supporters get through
every day being in constant fear of
everything black lives matter critical
race theory masks how do they function
well
by its definition reactionary politics
is about making people afraid of stuff
they're going to make your kid gay
they're going to make your kid trans
they're going to make your kid be
against slavery they're going to make
your kid be against racism they're going
to make your kid be able to think for
themselves it's all scary out there
and um
[Music]
yeah i mean that that's that's the
definition of reactionary politics
that's what it is
you make people afraid
let's see what's happening over on
newsmax to take the stage there when he
walks out we will bring it to you live
and you can see the energy is high as
always a saturday night america save
america rally there's a very interesting
article i talked about recently which
makes the case that trump's dwindling
rally crowds they do seem to be
shrinking
more quickly than trump's
hands
um that it is a sign of his kind of that
it's a weakened trump and i just don't
think we know
for sure we'll have to wait and see how
trump is due in 2022 we i just think
it's too early to say but it would be a
great sign
it would be a great sign
um super chats as a democrat supporter
myself i feel torn on newsmax because i
know it's right-wing insanity but they
always have my favorite celebrity on and
then i can't help myself well said i
know that can be tough next thing you
know you're sending newsmax money it's
uh it no that's that's very very serious
let's give away a few more memberships
thanks to betty morgan
and joe rader we are now at 42 they have
each given away a membership those go to
jacob pita like pita bread love that
actually it would be interesting um well
anyway let's not get into pita bread
right now and jonathan robinson
jonathan roberson robinson no my
question was going to be whether our
audience is more partial to none or more
oh trump's here or more partial to pita
bread would be interesting
[Applause]
trump has never run early ever ever ever
that i can think of
a quick thank you also to angela leahy
and kelly robbins in all seriousness
guys before trump goes on
we've been doing
streams and podcasts basically every day
and i appreciate everybody who's been
supporting i have a very small favor to
ask you for i need 11 000 votes give me
a break no no no it's not illegal it's
not a treasonous faber favor i would
love for you to sign up on my website
joinpakman.com you know you have choices
you could buy my pillow with a coupon
code you can get a membership on my
website with the coupon code sadtrump i
really do appreciate everybody who's
been supporting us it's been a big
stream week and we're gonna i mean this
is now the election season we're gonna
be i expect three to five streams a week
from here on out and
it's your support that makes it all
possible so in all seriousness i really
do appreciate it uh we will thank
everybody you'll see the the timer tick
up the meter and hopefully explode off
the screen
i think they're doing the country song
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it'll be a pretty weaponized rally i
expect many lies i expect many
distortions
the mag space karen says the mega crowd
looks flash more flaccid than usual
yeah no this is not exactly
this is not exactly a thinking man's
crowd i think is maybe the way we would
we would say it alright let's listen
obama
where's blocks for trump
i want to say a very big hello ohio
thank you very much
incredible people
i wish those cameras would turn around
and go all the way back as far as the
eye can see
but they never do that because
they're fake news they're doing it right
now
blue sparse crowd huh
i'm thrilled to be back in this
incredible state very smart
hardworking american patriots incredible
people
and seven months from now the people of
ohio are going to vote to fire the
radical left democrats
and you're going to elect an incredible
slate of true america first republicans
to congress and we're going to send j.d
vance to the united states senate let's
hope not
and together with god let's hope crazy
nancy pelosi she's crazy as a
bedbug we're going to end her political
career once and for all it's going to
happen
[Music]
and when she loses that position she'll
be out of there so fast she'll be
leaving
in 2016 and 2020 we won ohio and a
landslide
we wanted
by a lot of votes
probably should have won it by more than
that
and we're getting ready to deliver yet
another stunning victory for ohio
workers and families this november it's
going to be
incredible and i'm going to be with you
we're going to be with you all the way
for decades your state was ruthlessly
betrayed by globalist politicians and
you know it better than anyone we were
there with you corrupt special interests
and far left radicals who shipped away
your job shut down your factories closed
up your steel mills
opened up your borders and undercut your
wages and let crime gangs and deadly
drugs pour into ohio communities and you
know what i'm saying and we stopped it
we stopped it cold how
you brought back your jobs
how what did you do we brought back your
jobs all of that this time of day is not
favorable to trump's hair i i'm very
much aware of that and who put ohio
first that we did
proud to have done it
the fact is you got a president who
made america great again
obama
hold on i'm coming
and right now our country is going to
hell but under biden pelosi and the
radical dems it's
back to
america last they actually say it's
america last and that's what it is i got
gas
gasoline no you didn't
i thought he was going to say he
recently got gas
all you could buy no lines no nothing
now they have it to five dollars six
dollars seven dollars eight dollars and
it's going higher get used to it
i rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability we don't even like
talking about it but i rebuilt our
nuclear capability we had bombs and we
had explosives
just as like one fact check so everybody
knows how dishonest gas has already
started to come down it's already down
like six percent and it seems that
inflation's also going to start coming
down i mean listen it has it has very
little to do with trump or biden to be
perfectly honest but he it's just it's
all lies guys you you know that
force we created space force very
important stewing
greg so we created a
great new beautiful
military and they gave 85 billion
dollars of it away to the taliban thank
you very much including
700 000 machine guns rifles and guns how
about that jd we're doing a class-action
lawsuit against all machines the largest
oh steelers now in the world they sell
everything that they took from us they
shouldn't have had 10 cents worth of
equipment
they have our airplanes our helicopters
our tanks and 70 000 think of that
i don't think there's a used truck lot
or car lot
anywhere in the world
that has much more than five or 600 cars
you know they say the inventory is full
if you have 500 on the big ones 70 000
trucks 70 000 we gave them many of them
armor
plated
i was getting her safely out of
afghanistan
while keeping bagram we were going to be
out with dignity
with respect
remember when trump was asked what
exactly would have you done differently
in afghanistan he could name nothing
nobody talks around all of the
incredible soldiers that were so
horrifically injured you never even hear
about it i hear about it
no legs no arms
just blown up
disgraceful
we didn't lose a soldier i spoke to
abdul the head of the taliban
you didn't lose a soldier
in 18 months not one until that horrible
day the most embarrassing day
in the history of our country i feel
and they left hostages behind
they left the equipment but they left
hostages many many hostages behind
we created the safest border in the
history of our country they created the
most unsafe border perhaps anywhere in
the world i don't think there's a border
in the world that looks like that third
world nations have better borders than
we do right now what we have no idea
from where they come
last month
127 different countries were represented
by illegal aliens coming into our
country
many prisons are emptied into our
country they're getting rid of their
prison that's not true isn't that
wonderful
the safest border think of it the safest
border three weeks away from completing
the wall which i assume they would have
done very quickly yeah they were going
to do 1500 miles of wall in three weeks
guys we did a wall in record time two
and a half years we had to win 11
different cases many brought by congress
democrats in congress
but we did an amazing job we had the
safest border in the history recorded
history of our country now we have the
worst border in the recorded history we
did a great job with the drugs coming
through human traffickers we had
virtually no inflation
they have the highest inflation in 47
years
and going much much higher
which is costing families six thousand
dollars a year that's bigger than any
tax increase ever proposed i doubt it'll
go much higher maybe one more month but
i think it's about to start coming down
myself in the history of the united
states
biggest
biggest tax cut in the history of our
country
and they intend
to give the largest tax hike
in the history of our country so they
can do they can be a new deal and waste
a lot of your money they'll be lucky to
get anything done
a lot of your money people that don't
even know anything about the environment
came up with the idea it's a hoax just
one of many hoaxes you know that
we had 160 million people working
they have millions fewer people working
millions and millions fewer
and a lot of people don't even want to
go back to work it looks like they're
not going back to work
the numbers are totally
phony numbers they say three and a half
four percent but you're talking about a
whole different deal we had wait if the
unemployment numbers are phony how can
he trust the labor participation numbers
aren't they
that's weird isn't it
and they're trying to destroy our
country with a climate hoax
that will close down our businesses
destroy america economically
make our country impossible to live in
and have us be the laughing stock of
every
country in the world how about the paris
environmental accord
a trillion dollars i ended it and one of
the first things he did let's give him
back a trillion dollars and it's
probably more than that every single
year a trillion dollars joe biden didn't
send a trillion dollars to anybody sick
under our leadership we were respected
all over the world our country was
respected they may not have all liked me
but they respect gallup and pew surveys
both had the you respect for the u.s
under trump historically low it's
recovered since biden took over
that hadn't been seen for decades and
now our leaders
of countries don't even return the
president's phone call they don't even
call him back that's untrue you've been
hearing about that we cut job-killing
regulations for
individuals and businesses at the
highest level in the history of our
country
and they're working feverishly to put
all of those horrible
regulations back i think the regulations
might almost have been more important
than the tax cuts whenever you ask trump
what regulations he cut he can never
tell you the president came close to
what we did whether it was four years
eight years or in one case more
we had tremendous success in covid with
therapeutics and operation warp speed
that even the
other side said what you did with warp
speed was incredible donate plasma
now you look at the biden administration
was unable to
get the tests done
they created unyielding and
unsustainable and totally horrific
mandates and radical mass regulations
and we did just the op
and we had far better success in every
single category except for public
relations you know we were too busy
working to think about public relations
they do a lousy job except they have a
fake news a fake press these people
right back here they report fake stories
all
all day long
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh very powerful light
important it is so like as an example
i thought the cameras
i this happened this has been happening
for a long time nobody my wife
calls me how is the crowd
i say uh i say sir
it's huge
when i call up i say so
how did it sound how did it look on
television
did i look good was my hair in good
shape
not right now i hate to say
and oftentimes you know she gives me she
said
i mean i had 87 000 people there's no
way trump has phone calls with melania
right there's no way in hell
i said all right how did i look not
great the hair wasn't good i said that's
so good
now who would say that except somebody
that's very honest and i think loves you
very much right how was your hair always
just wonderful
but we've done uh we've done a job that
i don't think anybody you look at this
crowd as far as the eye can see but i
always said you know there's like half a
million people at the crowd right now
cameras were probably fixed i thought
they may be fixed so you couldn't turn
them and then one day there were a
couple of trouble makers way in the back
corner and those cameras were ripped
around and that steel bench there's two
particular hairs that look almost like
octopus tentacles just flapping around
looking for purchase they refuse to do
it they sit back there nice and smug
but you know what we're getting the word
out better than anybody's ever gotten
the word out anyway
in the last year more people died under
the biden administration than the trump
administration nobody knows that we got
rid of nafta the worst general or from
kobe and replaced it with the
you're making a lot of money
one of the best trade deals ever made
remember usmca is almost identical to
nafta that it replaced
are trying desperately to renegotiate
the deal and jd i don't think you'll let
anybody don't let it happen
they killed us for
decades with that horrible deal
and now we have a good deal and it's
fine for them but they want to
renegotiate it don't let it happen
we put taxes and tariffs on china and
took in hundreds and hundreds of
billions
billions of dollars
we saved remember that american
companies pay the tariffs on chinese
goods china doesn't pay the tariffs it's
a big industry okay people don't realize
it i had a man come in from world people
the chairman of whirlpool and he came in
to see me when i was president-elect
and he said sir i'll tell you it's
really terrible what's happening we're
going out of this
[Music]
oh
and he said we have to do something sir
we uh
i sat down with the whirlpool people and
we put tremendous tariffs on all of
those machines that were being dumped
they were being dumped into the united
states we put tremendous tariffs on them
taxes and tariffs
and south korea it's hard to do that
sorry about that but south korea and
china primarily
and that is now one of the strongest
businesses we have in our country and
it's one of the greatest businesses in
ohio
talking about another two months if we
didn't do and i want to just
congratulate that particular chairman
he's retired now but he sat down and he
cried before me what they were doing to
this industry and i said we're going to
do so if we were doing bingo we would
all have bingo by now
i went up to the whirlpool factory where
they make it and it was incredible and
it's crazy how many people come up to
trump with tears in their eyes it really
is
and then we changed some rules too you
know i said what's the problem can we
help you well they don't give us any
water for the dishwasher what does that
mean
that we don't have enough water oh
please ladies usually mostly please do
the right
he'll say it was a terrible thing he
said he said only the ladies why no no
there's some men out there too they're
not so happy about it either
but in the dishwashers as an example
they had a little problem what was the
problem they didn't give you any water
and there was so little water that you
couldn't wash the dishes so what do
people do they kept pressing and do it
again do it again do it again so by the
time you do it 10 times the dishes are
finally there because he's doing it
electricity and you spend more water
than if you did it right
so i had a regulation where i let you
have all the damn water you want for
your dishes
and the same thing for your clothing
same thing for your clothing for your
dish for your dishwasher is great but
for your washes and dryers
in the washers they had no water coming
out and i just asked these simple
questions to the head of whirlpool who
the hell knows better than him
i said you have a problem yeah the
problem is
there's not enough water i also did it
by the way uh-oh for your sinks do you
ever go to a new home you buy a nice new
home because of the trump policies hopes
we're going up like crazy by the way i
hate to tell you the stock market
dropped over a thousand points on friday
lots of luck everybody
but you ever go into a new home and you
turn on the faucet
and there's no water comes out they have
restrictions and you know we're talking
about places you don't have a water
problem will he do toilets will he do
toilets you do have a water problem you
have too much water you don't know what
to do with it
so they have restrictors so you're
sitting there washing your hands and
it'll come on water come out baby i want
to wash
i got rid of it same thing with showers
i'd go into a shower
and i'd go to a hotel that was new and i
said i can't stay in these places why
the water just drips out a little bit
slowly i want to take good care of my
hair will they do toilets
no it's true
i mean i put the soap in it takes you 20
minutes to have the water come out to
get the damn soap out of your hair
but uh
and i won't talk about the third element
of a bathroom because every time i do
the fake news only talks about that but
you know what i'm talking about
one time two times five times ten times
no water comes out so i totally
took that out and we
made it so that when you have a sink you
can actually wash your hands normally
and you can take a shower
and you can do that other thing normally
all right the third element of the
bathroom
so we did it with the dryers we did it
with what we did with the dryers what we
did with the electric was great but we
did it with the this is the greatest
comedian of all time i mean
the country is is humiliated by it
manufacturers wanting to do the job and
so many of them were based here
has there ever been a a president as
obsessed with plumbing as this guy
regulation so that when you go into a
house
when you go into a house you can't get
any water so we're going to fight on
that and jd and everybody is going to be
fighting and that we finally have it
down to has it been five minutes on
bathrooms
where you have some sanity
the fact is the election was rigged and
stolen and now our country is being
destroyed what a transition country's
being destroyed our country's going to
hell we've never had anything
like this and we have a president right
now sadly who has absolutely no idea
what the hell is happening
he's shaking hands with the air
he's walking around
somewhat bewildered i'd say it's no good
and
taking orders from the easter bunny you
saw that one no no
no you know the easter bunny was a
political operative
he did a good job actually that guy we
should hire that guy he was very good he
said no no don't talk don't talk don't
talk to those people
and he's doing all of this while putin
does nothing but talk about nuclear
weapons and destroying the world
we have our signals very crossed in our
country we've never had a
situation like this the choice this
november is very simple
if you want to keep america in a death
spiral of crime look at what's happening
on crime with these democrat-run cities
chaos craziness corruption and historic
national
catastrophes you i can't believe he did
five minutes about bathrooms it's it's
unbelievable
if you want to have a country
that's going to
be great again
you must vote and again thank you that's
very good very good i like that guy
again and again and again
you know we had it great again and then
we said i think we should do a comma
make america great again again
you know our new slogan
our new slogan
our new slogan was keep america great
the problem is they've done such damage
we cannot really say right now and very
sadly that america is great we're not
respected anyway no we're not it doesn't
sound very patriotic it's very sad
what's happened so we'll say make
america great again again okay
but you have to vote for america first
these two women in the back are like
wait how many times have you been
flushing and this woman's like i've been
flushing four times and she's like yeah
me too what's he talking about group of
extremists then the treacherous crusade
against american energy and ohio energy
they see what you're doing to your
energy and your energy industry with
their
fake green new deal policies biden and
the democrat socialists have done what
our worst enemies could never ever have
dreamed of doing to our country what
they have done to our country in so many
different ways but look at energy
our opponents are
deliberating
and deliberately
crippling the most energy-rich
nation on the planet we walk on liquid
gold we walk on liquid gold
and they want us to buy from venezuela
let's go over to venezuela the dictator
that everybody hated so much
and now we're supposed to be buying
energy from
the dictator from venezuela who's
pushing everybody out so he can have a
country all to himself it'll be him and
about 30 people they're all pouring out
of venezuela we had venezuela already
they're crushing domestic production
driving up prices beyond none of this is
true i mean it's impossible to factor
for all intents and purposes waging an
economic war against
our very own citizens and that's exactly
what it is one and a half years ago
we were energy independent
never happened
before in our country
and today we're begging opec opec is a
name you didn't hear about opec for four
and a half years that's not true and now
you do as well as russia
and they're getting
the oil you know one of the problems we
have with russia they've never sold oil
for so much so it comes in through the
back door into the united states we're
begging them can you imagine we have
more than anybody
and we're begging them
for oil
they gave up
first day in office they gave up anwar
the biggest site anywhere in the world
in alaska probably bigger than saudi
arabia
and it was
ronald reagan could not get it done
nobody could
60 years
six decades they couldn't get it done
interestingly a friend of mine called me
up he's in that business but had nothing
to do with anwar he said i heard you got
anwar done as part of our tax bill
i said no actually we don't anybody know
what it means to get anwar done
murkowski she wasn't pushing and she's a
terrible senator from alaska so i said
we should get rid of her you should be
smart and get rid of her write to all of
your friends in alaska say don't vote
for makowski
so she approves somebody the first day
the person goes into office and they
write out anwar but a friend of mine
called up he said
what do you think of the ny said i don't
care apparently there's low-flow shower
heads all over anwar
they said well you know it's amazing i
don't care i have no skin in the game
but anwar has been tried for 60 years 65
years they've been trying to get it it's
the biggest site probably in the world
it's incredible i thought you might have
gotten it would be a hell of an
accomplishment i said are you sure about
that
really dynamic speaker look at how
engaged the crowd is by the way you know
when i told you i didn't care about
anwar i put it in the bill and we got it
approved
see he didn't know
he didn't know but that's the way it
happens mike
the environmental extremists and they
are extremists they're destroying our
country are trying to replace covid
crisis hysteria
with climate crisis hysteria and they're
trying to replace covid emergency powers
with climate emergency powers you see it
happening all the time and by the way
you see what's happening also with the
masks they want the mask to start
because they want it for the election jd
they want the is anyone wearing masks at
this point and they want those mail-in
ballots where they can cheat like hell
they're trying to figure it out
and these extremists don't use the term
global warming anymore because it was
getting cooler and the term wasn't
working so now they simply use the word
climate change
because that cover is if it gets cooler
or hotter or water up watered down it
doesn't matter whatever the hell happens
climate change you're covered we're 100
covered they went through all the global
warming stuff but it was just not
playing climate change no matter what
happens
when you say that you're okay
in the republican party we reject every
single left-wing energy mandate and
restriction
just as we reject covet mandates and
covet restrictions and they want to put
them back home
and with your vote this fall we will
shut down biden's energy war on their
country and on ohio you know you're a
big energy state a lot of people don't
realize that very big you look at ohio
you look at pennsylvania remember texas
where
biden's against energy
right
he's against energy
and the democrats no energy no god no
guns we're talking about taxes
oh the election's going to be very close
in texas you know why they say that if
they can steal enough votes and if they
can win nobody's going to be looking at
it that's all we killed him in texas
just like we killed him in ohio
and just like remember trump defeated
biden by the smallest margin for any
republican in more than 40 years in
texas
the actions of the far left radical
democrats show pure contempt for our
country and our people thank you
i always say they have the best seat in
the house
that's a good looking group back there
you know
see you people actually have i always
say it
movie stars they're look at all those
cameras from the fake news look at them
all
but they always turned the cameras off
for we took about the rigged election
then the cameras go off they don't want
it that's what they don't want to talk
about they never want to talk about the
rigged election
but look no further than their
program of totally open borders can you
imagine somebody wanting open borders no
now either you're stupid or you hate our
country it can only be one of two i
think trump's both
way that anybody can want open borders
the radical democrats have chosen their
side and they've sided with the drug
cartels
which is another thing the money is so
big these guys there has to be something
going on because nobody could want open
borders where
hundreds of countries are pouring in and
and they are really look these people
are very streetwise their leaders these
are
dictators presidents prime ministers
they're very smart people they're taking
the people they don't want and they're
putting them into
large groups of people the caravan i
think i came up with that name i call
them caravans and they're pouring into
our country trump came up with it yeah
talks to him they just pour right in
nobody said it before you can want that
they've sided with these drug cartels
and human traffickers
almost all
trafficking in women
mostly women
and child smugglers and criminal aliens
and savage thugs of ms-13 and by the way
i want to pay my compliments to
our great law enforcement in this
country and also to
border patrol and ice
border patrol and ice are incredible
what they have to endure
and then they have no backup from
government and then they say defund our
police
nobody here you know i know some of the
people in these rows right here
and they're very tough people very tough
they don't want to work for ice
they don't want to go into one of those
packs they call them a pack
and these are people that use knives
rather than guns because it's more
painful they cut people up they cut them
up and they cut them up badly and these
ice people they walk right into those
packs and they start swinging because
unfortunately it's the only thing they
know it's the only thing that the
the ms-13 gangs probably the worst gangs
in the world that's the only thing they
understand is this toughness but they do
an incredible job and and they should be
greatly respected they're incredible
patriots and border patrol incredible
incredible patriots and we have to thank
them and your police are one of the
things i will never understand about the
whole border patrol thing is
if they built the whole wall and it
really worked
a ton of those border patrol agents are
getting laid off because you're not
going to need them anymore any need them
if the wall were to actually work as he
claims it would nobody nobody seems to
think about that i think they want to
get rid of our country because nobody
can really believe this stuff just 15
months ago
we had ended catch and release
stopped total i mean like just stopped
asylum fraud
deported thousands and thousands of gang
members the hell out of our country and
we built
nearly 500 beautiful miles of border
wall exactly as the
border protection agencies wanted we did
it to their specs
but not but right now
right now
the biden administration has blown
someone in the back is yelling we know
you're the president only one month from
today joe biden has vowed to terminate
the title 42 protection that i put into
place which gave us guys if covet's over
why do you need title 42 of good
protection you know i had mexico title
42 allows rapid removal of undocumented
people on the basis of a public health
emergency they don't believe there's an
emergency so how do you justify keeping
title 42 the 9 or the 15. give me the
things you want most
and maybe you've heard this i've told it
very seldom but i'll tell it to ohio
because i happen to love the people of
ohio i worked in ohio
i worked in ohio he was a janitor more
than a year in the queen city you know
what the queen city is cincinnati
swifton village
job called swifton village with my
father we bought a job in ohio swifton
village and we fixed it and made it good
most people apply to jobs trump buys
them i know the state very well and i
love the people of ohio i love the
people of ohio
great people
and we can tell you
we're gonna tell you plenty of stories
maybe i'll tell you the story a little
bit later about how great our military
is should i do that
all right
[Applause]
thank you very much
bikers for trump thank you very much
thank you very much
but mexico so we had uh
meetings
i met with a wonderful woman in the
state department she's handled mexico
for 25 years i met with her and some
other people and law enforcement that
focused on mexico
and i said give me the 10 to 12 things
you want the most and they looked at me
like
not going to get them
and they wrote 12 things out i looked
and one of them was military along the
border mexican military but they don't
even they didn't even write the whole
thing out they just said some military
because they said you're not going to
get them i said of course i'm going to
get them why would you say i wouldn't
give why wouldn't they give us free
soldiers wow right why wouldn't they do
it they laughed at me like i was trump
wants to buy people just like he buys
jobs
the aptitude test because they thought
it might be stupid they really didn't
they thought i was really smart so when
they think you're really smart then when
i took the aptitude test dr ronnie it
was a dementia screening
and i aced it and you know now they
don't call me stupid they say the test
turned out trump doesn't have dementia
is i guess what we learned from it they
used to call me jd uh they made they
said maybe stupid so i said
to doc ronnie you know doc ronnie is now
a great congressman in texas great very
popular guy i think he won by like 52
points or something but he's now a great
congressman i said ronnie
i don't like when people call me stupid
i had great heritage an uncle who was a
great great genius oh no father who is a
genius everybody we have a lot of
geniuses i don't like being called
stupid is there a test or something i
can take to prove to these radical left
maniacs that are much smarter than them
is there a test and he said
sir there is a test it's called the x
test
i said what's it like you said well it's
uh it gets very tough the first
questions are easy yeah and the
middle of the test gets sir you're going
to have to remember three words for 10
minutes and later recite them back to me
what happens if i don't do well
he said well you know it's uh it's at
this great hospital you know our great
military hospital we all know our
military hospital the test is on a
single sheet of paper you don't have to
be at a hospital to do it said walter
reed i said
uh
let me take it
he said sir here's the problem if you
don't do well everyone's going to be
reading about it on the front page
if i do do well nobody's going to talk
about it that's the way it works with
the fake news they don't talk about it
so i said he said and other people are
present while you're taking it sir
i said let's go dr ronnie give me that
goddamn test right
i want to take that test and then give
me that test doc ronnie
so they gave it to me and they started
asking questions and some you know
around the third or fourth or fifth
question sir
sir
name five things they name five things a
light
a group of people
that's not one thing
a group of people is not one thing oh
that's genius
a fake teleprompter that i never end up
using
he uses it at every speech
and the fake news i'm i'm i think trump
failed the test you 20 minutes later
name the five things you named
and i hid it perfectly whoa that's a
thing they say nobody hits that one and
when we told that you know we told it on
fox i hope fox gets all straightened out
whoa i hope they get all straightened
out but we told it on fox and everybody
oh that's so easy that's so easy i say
you do it let's see you do it so far i
haven't found anybody that's been able
to do it jd it's not that easy nobody
can do it everybody has them took the
test
and aced it ace it means i got every
single question right
and i actually think especially in you
know what we're going through now i
actually it's like acing a you know a
blood test for hiv it's like you didn't
ace it you don't have hiv
but i aced it i did well but getting
back to mexico so i said give me the
thing so it was all these things and
i said no uh we're gonna get every one
of them and everybody in the room was
sort of smiling and laughing and saying
this guy doesn't know what ellie's
talking about we've been working on this
for 25 years so income is the highest
representative of mexico right under the
top right under the boss who happens to
be president a really nice guy i really
like him he's a socialist but i like him
he's one of the socialists i like see i
don't like nancy pelosi i don't like
schumer i don't like that seriously i
like to socialize is most known for
trading stocks not exactly a socialist
subversion he likes the president of
mexico but not these horrible human
beings that are destroying our country
so
i'm in there and i say uh
here's what we're going to do he comes
in
and he laughs at me when i tell him we
need 28 000 soldiers along the border
free
he looks at me like it's free
why would we do that we need something
called stay in mexico
that means nobody can come into our
country until we check them out and it
could take months and months and months
and he said we wouldn't do that why
would we
and the other things were even worse
and i said to the state department watch
they said we would never even consider
doing that and i'm ordered i'm ordering
you to stop asking for it i said i'm the
president of the united states you can
no longer order me but
okay
pretty tough guys
so i looked at him i said you don't
think you're gonna do this right
they said we're not gonna do any of them
why would we do we're not gonna give you
28 000 soldiers for free i said yes you
are
because it's now friday afternoon
at one o'clock
and on monday morning at 8 o'clock in
the morning i'm putting on a 25 tariff
all of the cars that you stole our
industry stole 32 percent
every car that comes into the united
states is going to have a tax or tariff
of 25
and every other product you sell into
the united states will be tariffed at
approximately 25
starting monday morning at 8 o'clock and
he looked at me he said sir
it would be an honor to have 28 000
soldiers on the border okay did that
conversation ever happen in frickin
mexico
we want to have stay in mexico
mexico and max we won every point max
was there max miller one of the great
guys max were you there
i've never seen anybody fold like that
they said it would be an honor to have
28 000 free soldiers and for two years
we did and that's one of the reasons we
had the best numbers in the history of
the border thank you soldiers were free
and great one of those things i hate to
tell those stories because it's not nice
but we know it's the way you have to
behave because all of these countries
europe all of them they take advantage
of the united states i got
billions and billions and billions of
dollars over 400 billion dollars paid
into nato
because i told them you're not paying
they weren't paying we were protecting
europe they were killing us on trade
they were killing you they weren't
taking our cars they weren't taking our
farm product they weren't we were taking
everything from them bmws we were taking
every car made by the millions that they
weren't taken i said to angela merkel
angela
how many
chevrolets
and she said why i don't believe any i
said why would germans who have
volkswagen audi mercedes who knows what
else they have
say let's bring chevys and fords i mean
no offense guys i know we have people in
the audience who work for chevy and ford
why would germans say you know what we
really need here instead of our great
german cars
we need a ford
come on
bmw i forgot we can't do that and also
protect them militarily so i told them i
said and this was a big story last week
because it was revealed for the first
time they probably knew about it but
they didn't like talking about it
because it was too positive but i said
to the 28 countries at that time
including us i said no if you don't pay
we're not going to protect you the money
came in by the billions it was amazing
the money came in by the billions and
that's why
that is why nato right now has so
much money
right now that 400 billion dollars plus
coming in the head of a major country
stood up are you saying sir
that if we're not paid up and they
weren't uh there were eight countries
that were paid he used the word sir over
a hundred times or under a hundred times
tonight what do people think i'm saying
okay
they started sending checks like
nobody's ever seen and
the secretary general saltenberg
said there's never been anything like
this bush went in he made a speech and
he left obama one made a speech boring
speech and he left
they always forgot to ask for money and
we were really protecting europe almost
100 percent
nato really didn't exist in terms of
what they were doing i got him to pay
over 400 billion dollars that he came in
very quickly now if i would have said oh
yes we'll protect you no matter what you
do it's okay they wouldn't have paid
right that's the way it works in life
but all of this money that you see right
now and i was the one that said
we're going to send in the tank busters
right remember we're going to send in
javelins you know that country now is
that i got badly criticized at the time
we're going to send in javelins and they
said obama sent blankets and trump sent
the tank busters that you have
and they did that to show how bad i was
how what a horrible guy it turned out
that i was the right one
because they would have had no defense
without him so
but you don't hear that anymore they
used to say what a bad person you know
he sent them blankets and maybe some
pillows did he send them pillows
so the very same people who piously
claim to be defending democracy are the
ones throwing open your borders
surrendering your sovereignty defunding
your police prosecuting your politicians
like nobody's ever seen before by the
way and those
you believe in all of those people you
believe in they're trying to prosecute
them eviscerating your laws crushing
your wages deluding your vote
and handing your country over to
millions and millions of illegal
foreign national
illegal aliens i would call them
all without your consent you haven't
consented to that on top of that you had
a fake phony election and by the way did
you see
did you oh what a handsome
president
well
[Music]
i said should i wear a red tie or a blue
tie is he having a stroke how about a
blue one he says whatever you want
whatever the hell you want
no that's a nice picture see those
screens are very expensive but on that
screen
you know we were paying so much for
those damn screens i said let's just buy
them
after about three events we could uh we
could have had them anyway but right but
you remember these rallies are so
profitable he could have bought
jumbotrons after just three of them
did a ballot harvesting
operation the likes of which has never
been done in this country took them
almost a year
and they found corruption in the 2020
election the likes of which nobody has
ever seen and i do believe they played a
little bit of it and i believe they're
going to be announcing it next week they
have found millions and millions of
totally corrupt votes any day now the do
you guys know any day the evidence is
coming out right it means
that is a blockbuster movie and the
press the fake news will do every in
fact even now as i speak two of the
lights just went off
[Laughter]
two lights just went off
that's obviously not true
this is called reactionary fear porn
every the the only people live are
newsmax and right side broadcasting and
they're both live communism that's what
that's when it starts when you have no
press we have no press those two lights
just went off they don't want to talk
about it
you're going to take a look you're going
to take a look next week at truth to
vote these are right incredible patriots
headed by
katherine engelbrecht who's an amazing
woman amazing amazing woman and you're
going to see things that nobody thought
now that was only one form of cheating
they had many more how about wisconsin
wisconsin now it's just taking a couple
years to get it all teed up building
homes and historically people don't vote
in nursing homes very much at a very low
level and in wisconsin they voted almost
100 voted and you know they found out
when the sons
and the daughters and the relatives came
in said my mom did not vote
she's comatose
she's been in a coma for months she did
not vote and they had her down as voting
and they were getting tremendous
complaints that these people didn't vote
and historically a very small portion of
people in nursing homes vote because
they have other problems we can
understand perhaps we'll all be there
someday could be with me too my family
will say get the hell this guy out of
the house
now that trump is much more health
conscious lately he's he's this is he's
actually bringing that is actually
interesting he's mentioning that type of
thing a lot nothing like that's ever
happened
so they have somebody up there justice
gableman he's an incredibly respected
man and his report has been absolutely
unbelievable of the corruption that took
place in
wisconsin the ballot harvesting that
took place incredibly in georgia where
there's a level of corruption that
you've never seen and in pennsylvania
what he means is biden one georgia
mostly they find in swing states because
that's the one they focused on
so uh you're going to watch that next
week i hope you're going to stay
watching it and maybe now if they want
they can turn their cameras back on
the biden border crisis is also fueling
the violent crime crisis in america
under the radical communist socialist
democrats it's open season on law
enforcement officers
never before and on law abiding
americans and by the way i know it's
possibly not politically correct but i
really don't care about that
i don't care about that
we have to give
in those cities that are being ravaged
by crime and people being killed
many many people sometimes in a week
worse than it was in afghanistan
remember 18 months we didn't lose any
soldier i told abdul
don't ever ever ever kill him between uh
between chicago and kabul i'm going to
kabul it'll be hell to pay like nobody's
ever had to pay and he understood that
he understood that
was very nice i had a very nice
conversation with him actually he he was
very respected he called me your
excellency your excellency
he said but why your excellency why why
did you send me a picture of my house
this story again
nice house actually
very nice house
but you know what for 18 months we had
we didn't have one soldier killed not
one and yet in our democrat-run cities
you have many people killed every week
and you have people shot every week
worse than afghanistan by far
hard to believe right yes but we are
going to do something about it and the
republicans are going to do something
about it and i was always torn
do i send in
law enforcement do i send in the
military into democrat-run cities i mean
the one good thing about happened with
this fake election is that this little
this little space people are seeing how
badly they're running things our
country's gone to hell you look at
everything and you look at the numbers
on lauren i think the teleprompter might
be running backwards he's repeating a
lot they're cities and i think i did the
right thing because if i sent in the
military or if i sent in the national
guard that say he's a dictator and we
did do that sometimes after a period of
time like
minneapolis we sent in the national
guard because after six days that place
was you weren't going to have a city
and they did a great job i sent them in
and we were going to send them into
seattle because they basically were
taking over the city and portland i did
send them in they were going to burn
down the federal courthouse by the way
do you notice that nothing happens to
those people right nothing happens to
them
but we have people in jail that are
police officers and firemen and others
and they're being treated so differently
committed crimes
cincinnati columbus and dayton all
democrat-run cities you have
skyrocketing murders rapes robbery
shootings
and carjackings at levels that they've
never seen before
this month right here in columbus a
three-year-old boy
was horribly shot when 15 bullets were
fired into his house
killed last month a one-year-old baby
girl was shot
while sleeping in her home lying in bed
between her two parents
when a bullet came through the wall
through the mattress and right into her
back
and this month a columbus man was
sitting on his porch
when two vicious thugs
tried to rob him viciously rob him and
when he said i don't have any money
please please i don't have any money
they shot him eight times and killed him
but help is on the way the reign of
defund the police democrats ends this
november and even more so it's going to
end in november of 2024
hey has anybody actually defunded their
police department
thank you very much
gotta end you're not gonna have a
country
between horrible elections think of it
borders open borders horrible elections
we're like a laughing stock all over the
world our elections are laughing stock
look at france they're having an
election you know what they do
same-day voting all paper ballots very
simple they have no problem
and that's what we have to get to we
can't have these elections trump voted
by mail
and they store the votes in a room and
where is the guard well he took off
today
why how come all these votes are being
moved around think of it think of what
they're doing
48-day elections we want one-day
elections we want paper ballots
and no mail-in fake ballots
but it doesn't apply to trump they cheat
like never there's never been an
election like took place in 2020 and you
gotta watch
you have to watch the movie next week
dinesh d'souza he did a movie on it oh
no but it's truth to vote this is a
group of unbelievable many many women
and you know what they did they went
through 50 miles of tapes because those
fake lock boxes that were being stuffed
all over the place
they have tapes in many cases government
tapes you know whose were the worst by
the way georgia a lot of the tapes were
missing in georgia the governor of
georgia has done a poor job poor poor
job and he didn't want to do anything
about it but georgia was one of the
worst
but they followed these tapes for almost
a year they've been rev and they have
people stuffing the boxes like you've
never seen before and you get just a
little glimpse of it but it was uh i'm
sure was eye shadow none of this is true
uh joe biden won the election changes
will be possible if we don't kick the
radical left democrat socialists i say
communist because again when you don't
have he says communist because he
wouldn't know the difference anyway
turning off their cameras where they
don't want to hear something when you
don't have a media that's going to
police the corruption in this country
then you've got yourself a big problem
but we're going to throw them
out of the house and out of the senate
this november so important
throwing the hell out of here and we
have to do everything to maximize
our chances of victory our country's at
stake it's all about winning we have no
choice we have to win we have to fight
they fight very dirty very dirty they
used covid in order to cheat in the
election by sending millions and
millions and millions of fake ballots
all over the place nobody knew what the
hell was happening some houses
were voted in biden once i won't say how
many because they'll say
how do you know that many many people i
could say in this audience but of course
this audience would have far fewer
if i went to another audience almost
everybody would raise their hand that's
why
i'm very pleased to introduce the man
with by far the best chance to defeat
the radical democrat nominee for the u.s
senate this november
so the thing when trump brings you up if
you speak more than 30 seconds he gets
bored and annoyed
he did
but you know what
every one of the others did also in fact
if i went by that standard i don't think
i would have ever endorsed anybody in
the country you wanted to
they all said bad but they all came back
but i will tell you he he was tough and
but the others were tough and they all a
lot of them said
some really bad things and ultimately i
put that aside
by the way he's been like uh incredible
in the last period of time long period
of time
and so have the others for the most part
i guess in all cases the others
but i have to do what i have to do we
have to pick somebody that can win and
this guy is he's tough he's smart he's a
former marine
he's a yale educated lawyer a great
student you know went to yale got a law
degree he's a great student he's a
fearless mega fighter he rocks like
crazy and
he loves ohio and he frankly he's a
great
buckeye so what i'd like to do is ask jd
vance
come forward i want to pick somebody
that's going to win and this man is
going to win come on guys yale's good
when a republican went there but
otherwise it's liberal critical race
theory indoctrination
ohio
do we love this guy
ladies and gentlemen all i'll say is it
is time to send republicans who know
what time it is we've got big tech
censoring conservatives we've got a
crazy fake president who will buy energy
from putin and the scumbags of venezuela
but won't buy it from middle class
ohioans
we've got a ridiculous leadership even
on the republican side and try to undo
some of the best things that donald
trump did over the past four years
things that no other president has done
that's true it's time to send people who
know what time it is ladies and
gentlemen that's why i'm running for
senate and that's why we're going to win
and take this state back
short
and praise of trump that's how you do it
now
now now now the
the president is right i wasn't always
nice but the simple fact is he's the
best president of my lifetime and he
revealed the corruption in this country
like nobody else
most of vance's speech is praising
[Applause]
trump now ladies and gentlemen
let me introduce again the republican
who knows what time it is the best
president of my lifetime the great
donald j trump
thank you jd
you get it thank you
so
jd is
really an america first warrior he
believes so much in making our country
great again and he's going to do
a job on these horrible people that
we're running against they really do a
number on them
all of them i can say a guy like bill
crystal is opposed to him once others
crying adam kinzinger
little ben sass from nebraska real
lightweight
cnn
msdnc new york times washington post
they're all
they're all looking to do bad things jd
is also supported by
a great group of people tucker carlson
senator josh hawley
ohio right to life horrible people
bob lighthizer steve miller my son don
we love don don't we
do you
and most importantly jd you're supported
by me i'm supporting you i'm gonna get
you
so if you want to deliver a historic
victory for america first here in ohio
and also
a historic defeat for the people that
are destroying our country
j.d vance is your guy he will do a
tremendous job when you cast your vote
you have to imagine all of the liberal
tears that will be cried and all of the
rhino tears that will be shed
when jd wins on election day
and all of you great conservatives who
will be celebrating
when he defeats a total lightweight by
the way ran for president
he was the only guy he had zero
tim ryan he's running i liked him ryan
is he gonna win i've been a guest on our
show he's gonna win the primary i guess
right does he have anybody in the primer
but he's not good he ran for president
he got zero
the prime but what he will have look
that's actually a good race to get
involved in by the way guys a lot of
times people say what's a good race to
get making sure jd vans is not the next
senator and tim ryan is makes a lot of
sense to me the other
people in the race i liked him a lot but
we have to pick the one that's going to
win this guy's tough as hell he's going
to win we have to pick him he's right
he's the guy
he's the guy
the primary is may 3rd but early voting
is underway right now so get out there
and vote may 3rd a lot of republicans
like to vote on may 3. early voting
which trump is against is happening so
do it now they say i'm sorry you've
already voted
by the thousands
i'm sorry ma'am you've already voted no
no no i wanted to vote on election day
i'm very proud there's a beautiful woman
walked in thousands thousands of people
i'm sorry ma'am you've already voted
some people left i didn't know what
happened some people cried and some
people got very angry got beyond angry
angry like nobody's ever seen
but they walked in and said i'm sorry
because they had somebody vote for them
and i can tell you they didn't vote for
trump i can tell you that right also
with us tonight
[Applause]
also with us tonight is
a person i know very well he was in the
white house with me from the beginning
he's a tremendous guy i had no idea he
was such a natural at politics but he is
you know it's just like baseball or golf
or basketball or whatever some people
are naturals and most people aren't this
guy is a natural this was a very
complicated situation on the districts
and he was at trump plus 12.
then he went and he said that's good
then he went to trump they changed it
they had some court
motions and hearings and decisions
and then he went to a trump plus eight
then he went to a trump plus two
then he went to a democrat district
and then he got a trump plus eight he's
got a hell of a district and he you know
what even when it went very bad for him
when he was in literally a democrat
district if there's such a thing i don't
think there's going to be such a thing
right there's going to be very few of
them
come november but max miller never
complained once he said i'll win i don't
care what i don't care who we're going
to win because the people get it and i'd
like to ask max just to come up here for
a second oh no
this guy's horrible really horrible he's
a great guy going to be
a tremendous congressman who covered him
before
he's like my boy
look at this guy
well let's hear it for the greatest
president of our lifetimes the president
donald j trump
this has real godfather wedding scene
vibes that's what i'd like to say
this man
sees something in people okay and what
you all need to understand is that this
man's vision
brought us the greatest four years that
we've ever had in this country's history
did he not did he not come on
so what i'll tell you is this what he
sees in myself whitsey season j.d vance
what he sees in madison jessioto and
mike carey are america first fighters
that are always going to work for you
people have it backwards in dc okay we
know very well that our main job is that
we work for you and you don't work for
us and that's why
and that's why i'm giving a quarter of
my salary back to the people of the
district and never taking a federal
pension that being said give it up for
the greatest president of our lifetime
donald j
trump
thank you max great god
obama
[Applause]
another person that i've known for a
long time always been successful always
loved your state and your people
and going to represent the 13th district
very well
madison jessioto madison thank you very
much for being here and i have a
tremendous
and a very handsome husband by the way
thank you very much
max and madison really uh
are incredible people they have my
complete and total endorsement a lot of
people said oh who are you endorsing
there's no doubt about who i'm endorsing
we're going to make that clear tonight
in politics you never know people that
begged for my endorsement that had no
chance of winning and you assumed you'd
be loyal to the party into our country
they ended up sort of being a little bit
the opposite
a lot of them wouldn't really have much
of a chance of winning so we take it
very very seriously but some of these
guys they wanted my endorsement so badly
and then they let you down guys like
mitch mcconnell oh
whoa lion brian kemp of georgia terrible
terrible
the lightweight senator from nebraska
little ben sass and others we had some
really bad people they want the
endorsement then as soon as they get out
they go after me but i go after them too
we're also joined by two really
incredible warriors from congress troy
balderson and mike
carey fellas thank you very much
light weights huh thank you very much
great job thank you fellas
they really have been they've been
fighting
against some very bad people for a long
time and fighting well and winning we've
been winning ohio state auditor keith
faber arden
wow good good job
just gave him my full endorsement today
full ohio secretary of state frank
larose
frank has our complete and total
endorsement you did a fantastic job on
redistricting and all the things you did
thank you frank fantastic total complete
endorsement both of them
ohio gop chairman this is a friend of
mine for a long time he was at the
beginning of my campaign he was right
there at the beginning i had a choice of
five people i said i like that guy's got
a nice polish name i like him okay
i like polish people
but i said that's also going to be
issuing some some uh half-hearted
endorsements later this
terrible governor that you had terrible
terrible guy
and he was fighting us and we had a
couple of other people high up in your
party they were fighting us and uh bob
would keep saying sir you're only going
up you're going to win by a lot i said
bob the governor's against me this one's
against me a senator's against me
they're all against me bob he said don't
worry sir you're going to win big and
you know what he turned out to be right
and i love him bob
benduck bob
great job he did a great job
another friend of mine and he was a very
very formidable
candidate and he happens to be very
nicely related soon very strongly
related because he's the father of a
magnificently perfect and beautiful
woman that max is going to marry
i think that maybe is going to be his
greatest achievement even though he's
been very successful
bernie marino bernie
hi bernie great job bernie thank you for
everything
great job great guy
he should go into the closing and in the
audience we have somebody doesn't know
he's going to be announced but i have to
because he's been out there and he's
doing a classic lawsuit against trump
he's been carving the name trump at his
farm and those planes would pass over
that farm you know who i'm talking about
and he's a great guy and he's in there
fighting for whatever the hell he's
fighting for i don't care i love him j.r
majewski i just interviewed medusa
where is j.r i just interviewed majewski
last week he had no idea we were going
to do is that j-r-u i got the uh
interview on my channel hello j.r you
didn't even they didn't even give you a
good seat jr
look at him yeah there he is we but we
love you j.r thank you very much thank
you man
this guy he carves that name trump in
those fields
he's a genius thank you really nice
yeah i did an interview with him on my
channel
hey jr you're pretty popular yeah you
got a lot of popular
support
thank you very much i appreciate it
remember i told everybody when i took
over i said go out farmers buy
more land and a larger tractor i was
right i got china to give us a lot of
money including handing you 28 billion
dollars out of
the taxes and tariffs i gave the farmers
28 billion dollars in manufacturers too
that's the first time china's ever done
that one
that's no the jr majewski is so popular
and so revered he doesn't even have a
seat at this thing delaware county
fair board for their incredible work
this evening this broke all of their
records their records
they told me this was honestly a record
by thousands and thousands of people and
as far as the eye can see you know
you're not going to hear that
you're not going to hear that but as far
as the eye can see people back there i
wish they had the press way back there
you know they have these cameras they're
fantastic they have these magnifying
lenses now we could put them way back
and they'll be just fine
they'll be just fine and i wish we did
that because they're blocking a lot of
great people from seeing but i want to
thank you all very much for being here
and great and thank you for your support
you could take
the five worst presidents in american
history
and by the way
mike stand
up mike we're doing a clown
lawsuit against all machines
he's a great patriot
he's a great patriot and he's the single
greatest buyer of ads in the history of
our country
what a joke this country giving
great great job what a joke he's a good
man
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them all
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done to our
country
in just a
short period of time yeah we're at about
the 68 minute mark so ideally trump
would start to go into the conclusion
soon we're going to be saying two years
we have in november we have it all
happening and then we're going to say
two years and then we're going to be at
one year it's happening fast when i said
four years that was too long
but the damage is so incredible that
they've inflicted on our country as
everyone here understands this is the
most dangerous period in the history of
our country because of the weaponry the
kind of weapons the nuclear weapons
never before has our world been so
unsafe because of that
the russia catastrophe in ukraine would
never have happened under the trump
administration
zero
zero
zero chance all those they did know
better all of those people
that are dead that you see lying all
over the streets all of that is so
senseless it would have never happened i
know putin very well there is zero
chance that this would have happened i
talked about it with him i knew he
wanted it but he knew he couldn't do it
right by the way he didn't do it for
four years there's a reason for that
same thing with president xi and china
we'll see what happens with taiwan
but i told him you can't do it and he
didn't do it for four years more than
that because you can add the campaign on
to it i guess
under bush russia invaded georgia
under obama russia took crimea under
biden russia took
everything
or they're sure as hell trying but
they've destroyed everything you look at
those cities they're flattened
and under me russia took nothing
nothing
they kept crimea and occupied the
donetsk and luhansk but different i took
their pipeline right i stopped there
and biden approved it right after he got
into office and
unapproved our keystone pipeline as you
all know but now i
that was a terrible mistake and if
they're talking about the environment
there's nothing better than that versus
the alternatives the left is horrible on
foreign policy horrible on the economy
horrible on the border
and horrible on crime other than that
they're doing a wonderful job
the only things democrats are good at is
using law enforcement against
republicans and cheating in elections
they're great at that
did great at that record setting great
the truth is i ran twice i won twice i
did much better the second time than i
did the first
getting almost 12 million more votes
that we did in 2016 and getting more
votes
than any sitting president in the
history of our country
and now we may very well have to do it
again won't we huh
let's hope he's going into the closing
watch truth to vote just watch it
isn't it called true the vote not truth
to vote i i don't even i'm not sure but
i think he's even getting the name of
the whole thing wrong several years we
accomplished more for this state than
any administration in the history of our
country i withdrew from the horrible
trans-pacific partnership would have
totally killed your manufacturing in
your auto industry we created half a
million new manufacturing jobs in my
first three years president obama said
there would be no more manufacturing
jobs we fought for ohio and we won big
for ohio and that's why you won big for
me twice and i appreciate it i will
never forget it
and when republicans retake congress we
will fight and we will win for ohio once
again
we are going to win we're going to win
bigger and better and stronger than even
before this week a trump appointed judge
liberated americans from joe biden's
oppressive masked mandate
[Laughter]
it's funny how
a ton of people who'd never fly or like
thrilled about it and i was very proud
to appoint
that judge is very proud of
what she did
and
it's a great appointment she did
something very brave
but now the administration is appealing
the decision
and we have to have our freedoms with a
republican congress we will also protect
parents rights
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender
transgender to our children without you
can't teach transgender to our children
what
isn't it amazing how that's become such
a big subject and who would even think
that that would be a big subject
what do they say save our kids
who would even think we'd be talking
about that i mean i don't want to be
pejorative but something tells me the
kids of a lot of these people are not
exactly going to be on the fast track to
upper management i think i would say
sadly sadly sports is that okay
you saw the recent race the
the swimming meet
where uh swim meet an 11 year old record
and they had one young lady she was
going to break that record by 1 8 of a
second she's been working for years
she's going to break that record
and the gun goes off and a guy broke it
by 38 seconds now guys i i think the
issue of transports is complicated i
don't pretend to have all the answers
but didn't leah thomas also lose some
races at that same
swim meet like it wasn't even domination
of every every event from what i've
been told
and this woman you know they put a tiny
little quarter of an ounce on one side
of those big marbles on that foot and
like it's 208 pounds or whatever the
hell and she's getting up
she's so proud she got it up here and
she's ready to
ah
then she didn't quite make it but she'll
make it but here's the problem this guy
gets it we will ban
men
they said have you lifted before no i
haven't really
it's so ridiculous and you know people
aren't supposed to talk about it even
the young ladies that are being just
beaten so bad so unfair
it's so unfair they talk about women's
sports it's so unfair
has trump ever watched women's sports
have any of these people at this rally
even cared about women's sports until
this not afraid to comment i'll comment
it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous
and we will get critical race theory out
of our classrooms and out of our
military
they don't know what it is but they
definitely want it out
thank
you and we're also going to defend free
speech because we don't have a free
press and we don't have free speech
anymore
our speech is censored by those people
right back there
before 2016
america had a free and open people
broadcasting this rally are censoring
trump's voice using social media to
bypass the fake news and defeat the
corrupt democrat candidate crooked
hillary clinton did anybody ever hear of
crooked hillary clinton
because you'll be in jail
now remember guys they're they're for
law and order but they want to lock up
someone who isn't even under
investigation for any crimes never mind
has been charged or convicted lock her
up that social media could be used to
challenge their own
propaganda i guess i did it well in 2016
but think of it i got like 12 million
more votes in 2020 and we didn't have it
so i don't know the level of power but
we did much much better the second time
but they were confused and they
conspired to ban me from every social
media platform on the face of the earth
millions and millions of you
had already experienced big tech's
vicious censorship
because of this digital tyranny we had
to give the american people their voice
back by
building something called truth truth
yeah no one's on it it's failing
miserably
and i think truth social's gonna do well
it's moving along nicely no it's not
it's failing you look at twitter and you
look at how bad
how badly it treats everybody and it's
betroth social but truth social phone
users can download the app today and get
their voices faux news what was that
phone news
oh phone users oh my god it's just
everything's strung together iphone
users are coming very very soon to make
truth social a free speech alternative
to big tech tech platforms
he's falling apart guys he doesn't know
what he's reading
and has recently enabled every single
person on the waitlist to join the
platform
now you can join as of last night i
think at 10 o'clock in the evening
big tech has banned so many americans
it's one of the most disastrous launches
and by the way mike pillow launched a
comp a competitor now we learned
accounts a lot of
phony accounts the truth social we're
canceling the plague
of radical leftists that's destroying
america we'll work with any pro-free
speech company we want it all to be good
just like we are with rumble rumble's
doing a great job
we've teamed up
to build this incredible platform
so go out and sign up now have a lot of
fun and finally we have no choice we
must restore
the integrity of our elections from now
on we must have universal voter id
citizenship confirmation
no more dropbox
drop boxes
yeah he just glitched badly what does it
mean to have citizenship confirmation
you can't even register to vote if
you're not a citizen what does it mean
that's the confirmation if you're not a
citizen you can't even register
you know if you spend a hundred dollars
more than five thousand six hundred
dollars or whatever the number is no
more direct boxes here's a guy gave 417
million dollars and most of it was sent
and shipped to democrat areas you think
that's fair in addition every state
should follow the lead of the patriots
in arizona
where yesterday carrie lake
mark fincham
and others filed a lawsuit to ban
electronic voting machines and replace
them with a
transparent hand count hand we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines
paper
paper paper paper we don't have to worry
about signals being sent down from the
sky
politicians on both sides of the aisle
have long criticized the insecurity of
electronic
voting machines if you looked at the
letters from
some of your
wonderful democrat senators you saw
kamala harris how she's doing his wife's
friend do you think she's doing a good
job as vice president
[Applause]
elizabeth pocahontas warren
amy klobuchar you see their letters
talking about you know the voting
machines are corrupt they got to stop
them they got to stop them all of a
sudden they say oh aren't they wonderful
this is not a partisan issue this is an
issue for our country everyone guys i
think my title was wrong this speech
hasn't been dangerous or unhinged it's
been totally normal and trust nobody
trusts him nobody trusts
we have to go back to one day voting and
paper ballots with only maryland's being
accepted for our distant military or
people who are very
very sick and we have to confirm like
trump he's very sick
voting and no voter id or signature
verification is absolutely killing our
country our reputation and our elections
people have to believe in their
elections they have to believe that they
were honest and if you look at even the
polls
a vast number of people feel that the
election
presidential election of 2020 was rigged
and stolen some of your followers
because you've lied to them you can't
have that and then you look at the fact
that these decisions that are being made
so bad and that our country's going to
hell and none of those decisions should
have been made holding millions of
ballots in storage is dangerous and not
acceptable
the only way
is a one-day voting and paper
ballots one day don't store them in
boxes
and then the boxes disappear and a new
box comes in
one day voting
one day voting you go one day even if
they made a holiday let it have a
holiday they
name holidays for everything imaginable
nowadays right let's have a holiday if
they want one day voting paper ballots
nobody's going to play games you can
watch them quickly we don't have to
worry about foreign countries we don't
have to worry about anything one
day voting paper balance
and if we're going to have mail-in
ballots we're never going to have honest
elections you can't have these books
were sent to everybody i predicted it
correctly last time i know he did give
me some credit for it i said it's going
to be a disaster what he means is
because i predicted it i had to commit
and just say it happened but none of it
happened
must get smart and end mail-in ballots
or you're not going to have any
republicans elected in this country
anymore
these people mitch mcconnell on these
people are so stupid
we're just going to be there
from the most important midterm victory
in american history this is the most
important ever
and we need a landslide so big that the
radical left cannot rig or steal it
as hard as they will try the one way you
win you're going to swamp them like we
did in texas like we did in ohio
like we did in florida like we did in
other states you get are so big there's
a point at which they can't do their
magic right they're crooked magic this
is the year we're going to take back the
house we're going to take back the
senate and we are going to take back
america and in 2024 most importantly we
are going to take back that very very
very very beautiful white house
obama
thank you very much
time to wrap and just in closing yes
please first of all we have to put jd
vance in the u.s senate so get your
friends and get your family get everyone
you know and get out and vote for j.d
without delay do it now do it then but
get out and vote
[Applause]
with the republican congress we will
fight for more jobs for ohio families
fair trade for ohio workers and more
ohio factories forging
more products stamped with that
beautiful phrase made in the usa
we will shut down biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in mexico policy
reimpose title 42 which is right now
being decimated by the biden
administration
and strengthen the ice and border patrol
patriots we will again
end and we have no choice catch and
release look at this guy right here
chain migration we will end visa lottery
and we will
finish the wall it can be done in three
weeks which was delayed with two and a
half years of lawsuits and other
litigation
all by democrats in congress we will
stop the democrat crime wave we will
give our police the power they need and
the respect they deserve we will not
take legal protection away from them
they want to take legal protection away
from our police let them represent
themselves that's not going to happen
all right we will restore
law and order in america
we will hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world
we will lead humanity back to the moon
and the united states will be the first
nation to learn all the astronauts on
mars we're very close to doing it
we will protect innocent life
we will defend our constitution
which is totally under siege and we will
proudly uphold
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our
great american flag
hold on i'm coming
our maga movement
make america great again is by far the
greatest political movement in the
history of our country nobody can
dispute it even the fake news doesn't
want to talk about it
they can't do it there's never been a
movement like it and it's also a
movement of common sense and it's a
movement of love there's great love in
this moment together we're standing up
against some of the most
menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people have ever seen or
fought against
despite great outside powers and dangers
our biggest threat remains the sick
sinister and evil people
from within our own country
there is no threat as dangerous this is
like classic fascist reactionary
fear-mongering select committee of
political hacks
and what they're doing to our country
while radical left murderers rapists and
insurrectionists roam free
nothing happens to them but no matter
how big or powerful these corrupt
radicals may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
this nation
belongs
to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and your
great american liberty
is your god-given right
from akron to toledo from cleveland to
columbus and from dayton to right here
in delaware county you inherit the
legacy
of generations of ohio patriots like
neil armstrong annie oakley
president william mckinley a man who by
the way happened to believe believes
strongly in tariffs to protect
the workers of our country
great president doesn't get enough
credit and the amazing
ulysses s grantham alyssius ulysses he
still can't get that right huh it's like
minneapolis ulysses
they conquered dangers they pushed into
new frontiers and they risked everything
they had for this beloved nation
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you
who are going to save our country
we're going to fight for america like no
one has ever fought before we will not
let radical left lunatics or rhinos take
away from us
what has been so brilliantly forged over
nearly 250 years
these are sick people who are making our
country sick but we are the doctors and
the nurses and the professionals who
will fix it and make it better and maybe
healthier than ever before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no victory we cannot have
we will not bend
we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never ever
back down as long as we are confident
and united the tyrants we are fighting
do not
stand a chance of victory because we are
americans and americans kneel to god and
to god alone whoa
that's pretty big huh
so my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we're on together has only just
begun it's only just begun this is a
movement like no other it's only just
begun and it is time to start talking
about greatness for our country not
other things that make no sense
whatsoever we want to start talking
about our country and greatness again
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious american nation
so with the help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land
we will make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america
strong again
we will make america proud again
[Applause]
we will make america safe again
and we
will make america great again thank you
ohio thank you thank you very much
[Music]
well what an event folks
what a day
[Music]
well i actually need to apologize to you
guys
when uh we started the stream i before
knowing how bad it would be i said that
this would be a dangerous and unhinged
rally
and it was wrong of me to use those
terms because they are not nearly strong
enough to describe what we saw
corrosive to democracy dangerous of
course sickening
trying to placate the absolute lowest
common denominator i apologize
i did not use
strong enough language
when i said this would be dangerous and
unhinged
wow uh
stephanie asks how do i do this and have
any hope
i don't see any way to combat this cult
mentality yeah i i don't i don't know
what the way is
uh
it's very depressing look at this guy
there he is there's the dance you were
people were looking for
wow
very carefully getting down the stairs
imagine have to be
being secret service and this is your
assignment you know
horrifying
[Music]
wild
[Music]
yeah at this point no normal republic
like to the extent that there are normal
republicans like there's republicans who
are like i'm basically socially
libertarian and i just kind of think
taxes should be a little lower and there
should be less regulation
if that's you you're not going to this
trash right the people that are still
going to this are bonkers
the backdrop is ohio a lot of
rallying for jd vance of course his
newest endorsed candidate well i think
this was the greatest rally ever and
there were probably 2.2 million people
in attendance there uh so that is it
folks that's going to do it it's been
another rally it doesn't bode super well
here's a guy trying to give trump his
hat
and uh trump says keep it though that
was the best trump's such a germaphobe
he said to the guy keep it
i love that
trump's like no keep it keep it
um all right well we might see you back
here next saturday i don't know a lot of
other things going on but between now
and then we will certainly certainly be
together again i appreciate everybody
who joined me everybody who signed up
got memberships our friend brian
wrestler gifted about six or seven of
them while trump was bloviating we will
see everybody very soon
good night everybody or good afternoon
depending on where you are or good
morning